the wizarding world is back with its
newest installment will there be beasts
will there be secrets and will it all be
fantastic here's what you need to know
before you see fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore
the fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore originally had a release date
in the summer it's now set for release
on april 15th 2022 this puts the movie
on track to debut just in time for the
easter holiday according to deadline
this particular opening weekend has
proven to be successful for warner
brothers in the past with hits like
batman vs superman dawn of justice and
ready player one previously opening to
big numbers during that window full
scheduled release dates were a change up
from the november releases that the
first two fantastic beasts films
employed the new date may be an attempt
to garner a higher gross for the third
film than its predecessors achieved
while the first movie grossed over 814
million dollars worldwide the sequel
brought in last at just over 654 million
dollars a new release season may be an
effort to trend those returns back in
the direction of the blockbuster
original harry potter movies whatever
the reasoning it remains to be seen if
this move will pay off but if past
releases are any indication warner
brothers may be in for a happy easter
according to the hollywood reporter
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore will pick up sometime after
the second film and continue to follow
newt scamander and his friends as they
attempt to stop grindelwald
who wouldn't like archances according to
an official synopsis for the movie
professor albus dumbledore knows a
powerful dark wizard gellard grindelwald
is moving to seize control of the
wizarding world unable to stop him alone
he entrusts madge's zoologist newt
scamander to lead an intrepid team of
wizards witches and one brave muggle
baker on a dangerous mission where they
encounter old and new beasts and clash
with grindelwald's growing legion of
followers but with the stakes so high
how long can dumbledore remain on the
sidelines this synopsis the film's title
and the trailers indicate that law's
dumbledore will play a much bigger part
in the movie than he did previously
hopefully answering some of the
questions that fans have had for years
about the mysterious wizard
for fans who noticed the significant
change in grindelwald's appearance from
the crimes of grindelwald to the secrets
of dumbledore don't worry between
flashback sequences polyjuice potions
and actor shakeups more than a few
actors have played the rootless dictator
throughout the years yet when fantastic
beasts and where to find them first on
mass johnny depp's version of the
character depp seemed like the
tried-and-true version of this era's
grindelwald however def's ongoing legal
battle with ex-wife amber hurd led to
the studio's ultimate decision to recast
the role but don't fret mass mickelson
is picking up where depp left off and
he's sporting an entirely different look
than his predecessor debs grindelwald
opted for bleach blonde hair and a
pallor so gaunt he looked like he came
straight from the morgue mickelson's
version of the character seems much less
eccentric right down to the eyes if you
look closely it looks like grindelwald's
signature heterochromia is still there
but it's much less pronounced given that
grindelwald is taking his rise to power
to a political level his stark
appearance change could be attributed to
his need to win over the wizarding
population as begins his war on muggles
as he says to dumbledore with or without
you i'll burn down their world he just
apparently needs his suit press to do it
there may have been a few shake-ups in
fantastic beasts casting but the
majority of the series staples from the
franchise's first film will return in
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore of course there's no
fantastic beasts without magi zoologist
newt scamander eddie redmayne plays newt
the wizarding world's most notorious and
relatable hufflepuff meanwhile given
that the film is titled the secrets of
dumbledore it's no surprise that jude
laws reprising his role as the much
younger dumbledore
also returning is jacob the series is
main source of comic relief played by
dan fogler if the trailers are anything
to go by fans are getting a healthy dose
of jacob centric laughs in the upcoming
movie though with the new wand in tow
the wizarding world's most notorious no
match might just be a no match no more
as much as fans love the heroes the
villains are equally exciting for a
franchise like fantastic beasts
queenie's descent to grindelwald's side
was a shock for most fans but the
trailer poses a few epic villainous
moments for her expertly carried out by
alison soudel and who could forget ezra
miller's electric performance as
credence barebone as he works through
his trauma while toning an obscurus
grindelwald may be the main show here
but his lackeys hold their own just fine
the crimes of grindelwald introduce fans
to newt's or brother theseus commander
but the new film's trailers imply that
calum turner will play a much more
significant role in the quest to take
down grindelwald joining the
anti-grindelwald movement in what seems
like a big way is jessica williams
ilvermorny charms professor eulali hicks
following up on her introduction in the
crimes of grindelwald and of course a
trip to hogwarts wouldn't be right
without a cameo from a young minerva
mcgonagall who alerts dumbledore to
grindelwald's plans fans didn't get many
scenes with newt's crimes of grindelwald
assistant bunty but it looks like
actress victoria yates is returning for
the third film and the trailer is
positioning her as a soldier in
dumbledore's first army against
grindelwald poppy corby 2s is also
coming back to the third fantastic beast
film as vinda ready to fight for
grindelwald with everything she's got
alternatively william nadylam yusuf kama
may have had a rocky start in the crimes
of grindelwald but leto lestrange's
half-brother quickly goes from a
pseudo-villain to a hero spurning
grindelwald's invitation and saving
nagini though letter herself met an
untimely demise yusof will be back in
the secrets of dumbledore to carry on
her legacy
for anyone who hasn't seen harry potter
and the half blood prince in a minute
michael gambon's appearance in the
second fantastic beast the secrets of
dumbledore trailer may have come as an
exciting shock however his cameo is a
bit of a bait switch while the trailer
implies that we may see an aged up
dumbledore grace our screens once more
the clip is just recycled footage from
the sixth harry potter film that's why
he's returning to hogwarts
and it's crucial he should return the
trailer starts with gamba and saying
memory is everything without it we are
blind without it we leave the fate of
our world to chance of course this
snippet is simply an edited down version
of dumbledore's speech to harry when he
takes the teenage wizard on a trip down
tom riddle's memory lane to his pensive
still repurposed footage or not the
trailer raised the question is michael
gambon returning to the wizarding world
and the secrets of dumbledore that's
doubtful as far as we can tell it's only
in the trailer for the sake of nostalgia
and grabbing your attention stranger
things have happened in the wizarding
world but as a different dumbledore once
said it does not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live
the fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore title sets fans up with
serious expectations in diving into
dumbledore's backstory according to
entertainment weekly back in 2007 jk
rowling announced that she always
thought of dumbledore as gay and
envisioned a relationship between the
hogwarts headmaster and grindelwald yet
the books barely hinted this plotline
given that we've gone through two movies
that specifically revolve around young
dumbledore and grindelwald it's been
frustrating for fans to again rely on
subtle clues rather than concrete scenes
or conversations detailing this
relationship
however we do see the former friends and
possible lovers square off in the
trailer implying that dumbledore broke
his no fighting blood pact with
grindelwald hopefully fans will also get
clarity on the paris history and
relationship when they spar
like his sexuality dumbledore keeps his
family history close to the vast however
he beardstall is returning as albus and
aberforce sister ariana and joining her
is richard coyle taking on the role of
albus brother maybe fans will get
answers on what happened between abel
fourth ariana albus and grindelwald all
those years ago presumably fans are more
interested in this history than harry
potter was
i'm not interested in what happened
between you and your brother but because
the trailer teases a big room of
requirement moment ariana and abel force
cameos might be as superficial as they
were in deadly hollows it looks like
able forth is already running the hog's
head in while ariana has long since
passed making it likely that she'll
resume her role as a portrait guide
rather than a developed character
there can't be a fantastic beast movie
without some fantastic beasts and it
looks like the secrets of dumbledore is
prepared to deliver not only do the
trailers feature some beloved creatures
like pick at the bowtruckle but we
finally have a name for newt's trusty
niffler another major beast to make its
way into the trailer is credence's
phoenix lending more credence to him
being a dumbledore now it certainly
wouldn't be surprising for this to be a
red herring but it's equally possible
that there's even more murky family
history surrounding the dumbledore name
than fans initially thought in fact the
title says the secrets of dumbledore not
the secrets of albus dumbledore there's
a very real possibility that the title
is pointing to the secrets of another
dumbledore entirely outside of credence
there are at least two other dumbledores
in the movie presumably they all have
some secrets
on top of the beast we have names for
the trailer depicts a new kind of
magical bird crab creatures and a
shadowy group of stingers all in all the
movie isn't shaping up to disappoint on
creature comforts
as famed wand maker garrick ollivander
likes to say
the one chooses the wizard mr potter but
for a wand to choose a wizard the
wielder must be an actual wizard right
if you ask any squib they'll probably
tell you that a wand on its own doesn't
wield all that much power it's just a
tool after all sure some wands are more
potent than others but then again some
witches and wizards are more powerful
than others and wands choose their match
so how is it that no magic jacob is
wielding a wand in fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore in the second
fantastic beast the secrets of
dumbledore trailer dumbledore asked newt
to give jacob a wand could there be
magic in jacob after all there might be
a reason why the wizards let a muggle
tag along on their quest for years and
an explanation for how he breaks through
a memory wipe
there are quite a few significant
characters from the fantastic beasts
films whose stories are currently
hanging in plot limbo waiting for a
revival it's certainly possible that
some of these seemingly missing cast
members and characters might show up
anyway but based on available info it
doesn't seem likely most notably absent
is claudia kim who plays the human
iteration of voldemort snake nagini
crimes of grindelwald faced a
significant amount of backlash for
setting the groundwork for voldemort to
essentially enslave an asian woman and
then later in case a portion of his
warped soul inside of her whether
nagini's absence is due to the backlash
against the character her casting or
because her arc with credence is over it
doesn't look like nagini will be
slithering back for the newest film
one significant change from the previous
films that fans may not have noticed has
nothing to do with the cast in the first
two fantastic beasts films harry potter
author jk rowling retained sole writing
and screenwriting credits for both
movies yet in fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore fans may recognize
a familiar writing credit on imdb steve
cloves
cloves was responsible for writing seven
of the eight harry potter films and now
it looks like close is back on his
broomstick to assist in writing the
newest fantastic beasts installment the
real reason for the assist is unknown
but it could have something to do with
the studio trying to minimize rowling's
involvement with the film in light of
her recent transphobic statements or
it's possible she just didn't want to
write the movie solo regardless the
movie will see yet another returning
harry potter veteran behind the camera
besides cloves director david yates
yates is a potter staple having directed
the order of the phoenix through deathly
hallows part 2 and continuing his reign
through the first two fantastic beasts
films the director returns for fantastic
feasts the secrets of dumbledore to add
a level of continuity that's rare for a
franchise so massive
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one